what's the greatest thing about being a
mom
everything i mean absolutely everything
you know it's
very early mornings but i am so excited
every morning it's like christmas
it's been nearly three months since naya
rivera's death
and now e.t is learning how her loved
ones are working together to care for
her five-year-old son josie
you love being a mommy oh my gosh yes a
source tells et that nyah's ex-husband
ryan dorsey
and her younger sister nikayla rivera
have decided to move into a house
together to raise josie
as a team as soon as naya went missing
we're told nikaila stepped in to help
ryan with josie
the doting aunt always played a very
active role in the little one's life
so it was never a question of whether
she would continue on the same way
no ryan and michaela are not
romantically involved
but they are committed to giving josie a
life that is stable and consistent
without naya
and they agreed that moving in together
was the best choice for his well-being
quote since the devastating loss of naya
ryan's role in parenting has of course
been amped up
he's the primary caregiver but has been
relying very heavily on nakayla
he would not be able to do this without
her help and involvement
you know i'm a mom now and i you know
what i love more than acting
is being josie's mom so i want to be
here for him and i don't want to miss
anything
our source also shared that ryan and
mikayla have leaned on one another as
they continue mourning the late
actress's death
quote they've also found comfort in one
another because they understand what
each other is dealing with
and they know how exhausting it can be
to be grieving in the public eye
while also trying to keep it together
for josie
as for anyone speculating about nikayla
and ryan's relationship
the 25 year old model offered this
message on her instagram story monday
seemingly in response quote in the
darkest time of my life
the only thing that is important is my
friends and family
showing up for my nephew even though i
can't show up for myself
i'm not concerned with the way things
look because no one can see
each agonizing moment we all endure
there are a lot of currents on the lake
the idea
perhaps being that the boat started
drifting it was unanchored
and that she mustered enough energy to
get her son back onto the boat
but not enough to save herself the late
glee star's body was found in lake piru
in california
after she went missing on july 8
following a boat ride with her son
all things considered our source says
everyone is doing really well
adding that josie is a very happy and
sweet boy
and ryan and mikayla have found moments
of joy and lightness
in this tough time quote some days are
harder than others
but overall everyone is doing well
you